foreign
[Music]
women need to start telling stories
about when a man fumbled some coochie
from them and how he did that let's
start identifying I've seen a couple of
these I have seen a couple of things so
this is not the one you've got no no no
dying once a man sent me a video of
himself jerking onto a plate we didn't
meet
he didn't know how to shuffle cards and
kept spilling it out and he would just
giggle it was good
that was jokes that was Joe it was
gut-wrenching [ __ ]
we went on a date on Sunday no sex we
were texting on Tuesday and he made a
sexual joke and I responded saying
that's too spicy for him he responded by
a in the car didn't I the man was mixing
up two days after a date instant block
oh he's mixing me up um the thing from
the next day yeah oh man set by 80 in
the car didn't I
what
foreign
[Laughter]
at me and he mumbled something under his
breath when I didn't respond he said
[ __ ] I said I like you he never saw him
again
[Laughter]
[ __ ] I said I like you
[ __ ] man that's too funny wow that's so
funny I was unwell and he took me to get
some flu powders this man sorry this man
flu powders that's what she wrote bro
I'm only reading what she said I don't
even know what that means
blue Powder this is what she wrote I'm
just like wow I was unwell and you took
me to get some flu powders this man gave
me his coat in the store because I was
cold we walked out and get grabbed by
security because he stole sweets put
them in the inside pocket of the of the
coat he gave to me
this is actually so funny
I couldn't get caught like that
I couldn't get caught like that
he made her the [ __ ] escape the
scapegoat wow sweets sweet of all you're
a grown man
sitting sweets
I would die off yeah oh 100 I would
leave her in this cute Garden oh God
take my coat and the sweet sauce I'm
gone I'm gone
all right no hand soap in the bathroom I
had to take the coochie off the table
after that I can imagine
yeah that's that's poor where's the soap
and see the Gucci off the table no
you're not [ __ ] jokes you're actively
not [ __ ] me
we were trying to pick a movie to watch
and he grabbed the remote and turned on
high school football highlights after
about 15 minutes I told him I wasn't
feeling it and he apologized uh went to
YouTube and played slash wrapped his own
song
no he didn't
so
so the scene is they're sitting down
they don't know what to watch on TV he
grabs the remote and puts on the
football football highlights yeah
after a little bit she's like big man
I'm sorry this is boring let's watch
something else he says say less YouTube
yeah finds his own account yeah finds a
song that he's put on YouTube
plays it and then just starts rapping
along he's looking at her just laughing
alone do you know the address of the
walk through the valley of the shadow of
death
those jokes that's jokes that's jokes
um
we were kissing and I'm sorry we were
kissing and he had visible pre-cum on
his pants when I noticed he said I can't
help it he got me wet as [ __ ] nah bro
no you got me wet as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow imagine bro I couldn't nah bro
that's embarrassing that can't work
that's impossible I can't run you got me
wet yuck
Brother come on man
help it oh hell you got me wet babes
I'm so I'm soaking oh yeah I'm drenched
down there oh that's actually making me
sick I'm bare damp I'm [ __ ] gushing
let's go
I literally tweeted about this three
days ago but he asked to use my bathroom
and came up with my wig on on the first
link
he sounds he sounds like a white rugby
brat sounds like a white robbery Bear
right rugby brat on his first black
experience oh saw the wig and thought
what's this put it on and just came in
in his underwear
[Music]
swing it it was swinging
mode style it was swinging yeah yeah you
know you know exactly what I'm talking
about in it the thing was the bubbles
I'm back
that's jokes oh my God that is funny
he was lying about being Blasian and he
got mad when I said I know both of his
parents
reply
she quotes that's not even my real mum
my real mum is Korean and she wrote
you're black
that's too funny you're black can you
imagine bro you're not Blasian I know
your mama and your dad that's not even
my mum that's not my real mum's Korean
shut up
I'm not entertaining this anymore bro
shut the [ __ ] up you're black bro uh I
just don't how can you lie so obviously
oh [ __ ] anyway
second day we were making out and we
were stopped abruptly looks me squaring
the eye and said like a psychopath
enough of this nice guy act I'm ready to
[ __ ]
I laughed in his face and left
now
I've weighed all night I've waited it's
been two days
I'm tired of this I'm tired of this nice
guy stuff I dumb bought you food I've
done bought you drinks we've been to the
cinema run me some Tom yeah run me the
post now my mid lips he stopped enough
enough this stops now this stops now
[Music]
I'm ready to [ __ ] yeah what are you
saying I can't take another second of
this [ __ ] this is blade blade
[ __ ]
[ __ ] man that's entitlement Jesus oh
[ __ ] ah he brought me to the club with
his friends and one of them told him to
go into the bathroom and roll up for him
even called him a little [ __ ] and
everything yuck
imagine James
roll go roll up for me little [ __ ] told
him and you come to the club with your
gal
oh Jesus Christ
I came to his crib real late
he has me waiting outside the car while
he's sorry I come to his crib real late
he has me wait outside in the car while
he gets everything set up
I walk in I walk into the side door of
his extremely dark house and I'm LED
down the hallway to his room where I see
tea light candles in the hallway all
leading up to his bunk bed
oh God bunk bed
like stats Grim but same time is
bunk bed [ __ ] have to smash too they
do they do I need sex too
it's really not my fault I've got bear
siblings I've got bear Simmons and
little room and I'm broke I can't move
out but I need the terms I need to smash
just the same as the next guy facts bro
I need some [ __ ] I need some oh that's
torment
we were on our way to my house after the
date and he opened up Safari to play a
song on YouTube the pawn he watched
earlier started playing at full volume
[Music]
um
oh
he scrolled to his very first tweet and
read them out loud one by one for 10
minutes he was crying laughing at the
random pointless tweets from 2012 then
looked at me and said I don't see how
you don't think this is funny
I don't see how you don't think this is
funny I'm like do you not see me
laughing I'm reading past James
this is how I used to think
why aren't you laughing
that's jokes wow that's jokes where's
the context bro that's what I'll be
screaming where's the contest that's
what I'll be screaming
right this chick wrote I went to kiss
his neck and he giggled T he and she put
this to him
[ __ ] that's my Scentsy
my Scentsy
you're an idiot
my Scentsy
his homie told him to come back to him
sorry his homie told him to come back
him up because he was beefing
so he calls some guy and asked to borrow
his gun dude says nah bro and hung up on
him I was so embarrassed
wow nah bro big man I need your gun I
need to back something nah nah bro hung
up
yeah it's just like
so you're gonna back him or are you
backing him what do you need the
hardware
the hardware
that's a joke
I have yet another one we went on a
movie date and he showed up in some big
ass jeans some Gators a sweater vest and
a Kangol hat [ __ ] looked like my
granddad wow you can go hat you know
Jesus sweater vest
that's impossible
he played his mixtape loud as [ __ ] on
the way to this movies ask the lady if
they do student discounts in Brackets
neither Russell students and then asked
me to for change to get popcorn at the
confession at the concession stand I
said no and he followed up with so then
what do you carry that back it would you
carry in that bag sorry
what'd you carry in that bag you got
changed so I can get some popcorn
so what the [ __ ] is even in there what's
in the bag why you got the bag then why
is it so big yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
those jokes do you do student discount
I used to run that box
always I used to run that for that 10
off 100 went a long way went a long way
did you student discount oh that's
crashing that's crashing that's crushing
went out with a dude who begged me and
my girl to come out he said he said he
was getting the shots because he knew
the bartender man's came back with one
big shot of whiskey and we supposed to
split with four people I bought me and
my girl shots and left
let me get you man some shots just come
up with a glass thing that's icky bro
let's take a sip each that's icky bro
she said it's fine I'll get the shots
that's mortifying that is mortifying but
yeah that was a thread that was a thread
that was way better than I thought it
was going to be I'm not gonna lie to you
way better than I thought guys thank you
very much uh for listening that was a
short clip from our most recent patreon
episode if you enjoyed it and you want
to get the full episode head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
link is in the description and once
you're there it's gonna cost you a light
humble three pound a month Tempe a day
run the P you know the drills head on
over today guys and enjoy thank you very
much
[Music]
foreign